good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy friday at a press
conference back on march 24th of this
year joe biden announced that thanks to
the regime change war he's decided to
voluntarily wage in eastern europe our
country the united states will soon face
food shortages food shortages are quote
gonna be real
biden said
now the reporters in the room dutifully
transcribed the words and wrote their
stories but you may have missed it you
may not have even heard this because
there weren't a lot of follow-up pieces
about these man-made food shortages that
joe biden was predicting and that's
weird if you think about it because food
shortages are inherently a big deal you
could argue they're even more
significant than say a slap fight
between actors at an awards ceremony
food shortages are historic events they
overturn societies they bring down
empires they often have if you've got
food shortages you've got a potentially
destabilizing problem on your hands
and now we do have food shortages
they're real as joe biden predicted as
of tonight at least 26 states are
reporting that half their retail stores
are completely out of baby formula that
would include the states of texas
tennessee missouri and iowa and many
others so these are major population
centers without enough food for newborns
in memphis and nashville 52 percent of
stores have no baby formula houston and
des moines are reporting similar
shortages in san antonio a city with an
unusually high percentage of families
with small children
57 percent of all stores in the city
have no baby formula
those are the numbers
journalist savannah hernandez went to
see for herself what the reality looks
like she went to eight different stores
in texas and not a single one of them
had any baby formula to sell watch
we talked to a couple moms outside who
said that they've been having a really
hard time finding formula and so this is
what we're saying right now the second
target that we've been to we first went
to a target in louisville and now we're
in frisco and as you guys can see it's
pretty much the exact same thing here
grocery stores pretty much empty no
formula to be found i've talked to a
couple moms who were telling me that
people have spent upwards of 150 on
formula on amazon some moms can't even
find the formula that their baby
requires
one mother telling me her child was
constipated needed a specific type of
formula couldn't find it so that's
what's going on
so that's real you may not like savannah
hernandez's politics but
she's got a video camera inside target
and they don't have any baby formula
so babies need to eat but they can't
is that a big problem well yes it's a
big problem how big we have a lot of
problems right now ask yourself is this
a bigger problem than say
using the wrong pronoun or trump voters
peacefully trespassing in a public
building it seems like a bigger problem
than that so you would think the bidet
administration would do something about
it and they certainly could if they
wanted to
they could do anything these are the
people who claim to have the power to
control global weather systems the power
to bend human biology to their will so
nothing is beyond the scope of their
powers
and yet in this particular case joe
biden is in no hurry to fix the problem
in fact he joked about it today watch
if we'd been better mind readers i guess
we could have but we moved as quickly as
the problem became apparent to us
oh if we've been better mind readers get
it it's hilarious because actually
nobody can read minds
joe biden's being sarcastic like your 14
year old daughter lay off dad it's not
my fault
okay so joe biden does not read minds
but the question is does anyone in the
white house read newspapers or watch
television news
supplies of baby formula were down at
least 20 percent as far back as january
that was not hidden knowledge it was
public knowledge it was out there if you
were looking
here's one representative headline from
the fox affiliate in west virginia wvns
back in february quote what the baby
formula shortage means for parents
there you have it americans were worried
about not having a baby formula there
was a shortage in february
but the white house wasn't concerned and
they knew we know that for certain
because brian dees who's the director of
the white house economic council just
admitted that he knew on cnn quote we
were aware back in february and we've
had a team on this from the fda and
interagency process since then
okay so joe biden has been on this
problem since february so why is this
still a problem why is it still
impossible to buy baby formula in stores
in san antonio tonight
well the white house has an answer for
that too and the answer is
greedy mothers
they're the problem
like kulak's hiding grain
counter-revolutionary moms in this
country are undermining america's baby
formula supply
they're quote hoarding baby formula
watch joe biden's flak explain
but if you are a parent who's looking
for formula right now struggling to find
what you need you have even a rough
guess of how long these shortages are
going to last what should parents be
bracing for here well we've already seen
an increase in supply of the past couple
of weeks what we are seeing which is an
enormous problem is hoarding
people hoarding because they're fearful
that is one element of it and people
hoarding because they are trying to
profit off of your fearful parents
now we're down to zimbabwean economics
we don't have enough to eat because
greedy people are hoarding it it's your
fault america's moms you and your
piggish little babies always
thoughtlessly eating eating eating
eating show some patriotic restraint and
stop buying so much food for your kids
you greedy wreckers
that's the white house position on the
baby formula shortage
in fact and it's possible this will not
surprise you the reality
is just the opposite of what you heard
america's moms are not hoarding baby
formula because they're greedy or their
fat little babies are eating too much
sorry gensake
the bite administration is hoarding baby
formula
the administration's wic program
formerly known as special supplemental
nutrition program for women infants and
children is by far the largest purchaser
baby formula in the united states that
is true no matter what they're telling
you from the podium at the white house
here's how it works
states award a contract to a baby
formula manufacturer to provide the
product to wic participants
then people who receive wic benefits
take a voucher to the store and buy the
baby formula from that manufacturer now
government agencies get a kickback from
the manufacturer in the form of a rebate
sometimes as high as 85 percent of the
wholesale price in other words the baby
formula manufacturer essentially pays
the government to maintain this monopoly
and it's good business for everybody
it's been going on for a long time
the problem right now is that the abbott
nutrition company has made the baby
formula for the vast majority of wic
contracts
the government had all its eggs
virtually in abbott's basket
unfortunately abec has closed its plant
in sturgis michigan because of
contamination
and that means that millions of people
who used wic to buy avid products are
forced to buy competing formulas and
they're doing it all at once
so a government monopoly overseen by joe
biden caused this baby formula crisis so
what's the government doing to fix it
well here's what they're not doing
they're not invoking the defense
production act to manufacture more baby
formula of course not that's for
ukrainians only shut up american moms
instead the bite administration is doing
the opposite which is to say doing the
unimaginable
they're shipping scarce baby formula to
the southern border to benefit illegal
aliens who have the right to be here in
the first place
now we know this because of a florida
congressman called cat cammack here's
the video
this got sent to me by a border patrol
agent this morning and said this is
disgusting
you will not believe this they're
receiving pallets
and more pallets
of baby formula
at the border this was taken at ursula
processing facility where thousands
are being housed and processed and then
released subsequently into the united
states so
think about this this is what america
last looks like
that's real by the way the
administration does not deny that it's
real congresswoman cammack also uploaded
these two pictures onto twitter the one
on the left is from the ursula
processing center at the border shelves
and pallets packed with baby formula the
congressman wrote the second is from an
empty shelf here in the united states
reserved for american citizens
so there's never been a clearer
statement of the administration's
priorities hey american mothers your
kids are too expensive go have an
abortion and get back to work in an
amazon warehouse
congresswoman katie porter of california
said that out loud this week
you're poor have an abortion
get back to work
other democrats said the same try
breastfeeding exclamation point wrote 76
year old bette midler today on twitter
it's free and available on demand
it's been a while since she's done that
but that's her position so here you have
an elderly out of touch rich liberal
lady lecturing struggling american moms
to shut up and suffer in silence and by
the way make your baby shut up too
now if you can think of a more perfect
distillation of modern politics
of the left circuit 2022 than that
send us an email and let us know what it
is because we've never seen anything
that perfect
and yet
here's the interesting part
that's not at all the message that the
bet meddlers of the world are sending to
the millions of illegal aliens who are
flooding into our country
the message to them is just the opposite
come
we welcome you we will subsidize your
child bearing whatever it takes even if
we have to take baby formula for
american citizens we will help you
that's literally what they're saying
and more the point that's what they're
doing
so how do you get the bid administration
to pay attention to american citizens to
you let's say you need baby formula you
can't get it joe biden doesn't care
bette midler's mocking you go breastfeed
that's free
how do you get them to
awaken to the fact that you exist that
american children are suffering well
turns out there is a way to do that
the baby formula shortage we look this
up like every crisis in this country may
affect you
but it affects trans people
disproportionately because trans people
are always and joe biden often says this
are the ones who suffer most
and as congresswoman corey bush once
told us nothing is more important than
protecting birthing people
i sit before you today as a single mom
as a nurse as an activist and as a
congresswoman and i am committed to
doing the absolute most to protect black
mothers to protect black babies to
protect black birthing people
oh
well it's the last line that's going to
get joe biden's attention so your kids
don't have enough to eat they can't be
bothered to help you at all though they
caused this problem
but once joe biden finds out that the
trans community is suffering once he
sees the faces of that suffering he will
do all he can to help he'll airlift
those pallets of formula from the border
and distribute them to the many american
trans mothers who need them
once he sees these faces and here they
are ladies and gentlemen straight from
your calvin klein at pregnant men the
pregnant man emoji joe biden do it for
the pregnant man emoji
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight